this Honeypot attack tricks with a fake
system or network how first you want to
connect to a free public Wi-Fi then
let's imagine you're smart enough not to
enter your password but you still make
one mistake yeah you connected to the
wireless network congrats now the hacker
can start arbitrary Network and mitm
attacks
because can not only pass data between
you and the outer world but also change
it on the fly as soon as the wireless
network starts up Global attack scripts
are launched on the device and as soon
as a wireless client with an IP address
appears a barrage of targeted attacks
are automatically started against it the
script starts attacks over and over
again for newly connected clients now
hackers can automatically start any
computer attacks on your device curious
what else Honeypot can do watch our long
video in the comments be safe